I gotta be quiet guys where am I
doko desuka that's right everyone I am
in nihaan did you guess it from my neck
Oh headphones that's right I'm somewhat
of a Japanese I gotta be really quiet
this time the rule is simple you laugh
you lose and this time bring a new
meaning to the game cuz I don't know if
my neighbors will be pissed off so I'm
trying to keep it down
so we're so awkward recording in a new
space is new set up it's a bit more
intimate don't you think did you like
this feels more special
the really hardest part of this
challenge is the fact that I don't have
any gene fuel that's right I forgot to
pack it how am I gonna get through this
without G fuel this is impossible I know
but we're gonna have to do this together
we're on the same level now let's
freakin do this
[Music]
dan I have already lost ah
could this be the first time I ever lose
you laughs you lose oh my god oh my god
you know maybe that's a nice place down
there it's a lake in Paris very yes sir
it's a reservoir for them and the giant
vortex is a drain to prevent the dam
from flooding this is so sad can we get
some FS in the chants and smash like on
this video if you don't want ducks to go
down giant vortexes I expect this to get
a billion likes how do I make videos
someone remind me please
your jokes have always been stale Felix
nothing has changed I'm close now
okay reactions is over and over
how is your screen not broken yet
pounded real for once okay give me yours
broke Jesus Christ you knew it was
coming
this is still playing portal I didn't
know you call that a brofist sir annek
it should have at least gone to space
that wouldn't brofist anyone this is a
weakest brofist I've ever seen in my
life I'm not gonna buy you a new monitor
cuz it's clearly still working pathetic
try harder next time on an all-new
Sunday special bit I know you like to
say facts don't care about your feelings
but I want to tell you some facts about
your feelings
why did it see I can't oh god I can't
review this they're gonna copy strike it
tune in this week is that real oh my god
that's amazing on an all-new Sunday
special VIN I know you like to say facts
don't care about your feelings but I
want to tell you some facts about your
feelings
I can't tell if it's real it it must be
real that's amazing
god damn I I want to review that episode
so bad I can't do any more dr. Phil
videos after sitting the chat guys ever
seen the chat ok I've seen this I saw it
on h3 podcasts it's goddamn amazing let
me just preface my sorry sorry about
that
oopsie see oh my god
America everyone this does not happen
anywhere else maybe in Japan actually oh
sorry I dropped my contact lens
you're very glasses sorry sorry
nobody animals when they have something
on their head I can't tell if I'm the
only one laughing at these they're so
goddamn terrible wasn't she the girl
they used to go like stop shopping stop
or like stop bitching me she had a fool
all along Jesus Christ
[Music]
your life you said my god
Jesus Christ
years
oh my god
[Music]
what if we use a hundred percent of our
brains my god they figured it out life's
hacks that actually works I love that
that's amazing you get us gonna pay the
price
you guys are cruel God I've seen this
what is wrong with this girl
see now I can never sit on I literally
just sat on an airplane seat this
changes everything
it's like one thing to do with there's
another thing to film yourself doing it
there's an ant-man dies inside
I can't wait for me review there's so
many good thinners famous memes oh my
god these means I swear to God just what
is this Karen took the kids good
just get it up oh my god
people have way too much spare time oh
my god grind a you to really Grande what
are you gonna do that what is this here
Obama
[Music]
really watch out behind you it's a
creeper no oh here honey
okay all right that's not bad that's not
bad
[Music]
my god just stop these please they're
not funny and they're not good then
they're not creative oh my god it's the
best meme I have ever seen in my life
great stop stop it I'm actually hungry I
could go for some lasagna right now into
space to save PewDiePie feed mr. B's oh
my god
incredible oh my god that's insane
Jesus that's a good shot damn thank you
pro gamer J very cool sis Christ when is
it gonna end so I get to work this
morning and normally the first thing I
say to my color cuz hey guys how was
going well one of my co-workers decided
to ask me today hey dude you're into
fitness I was like yeah dude what's up
man he's like fitness whole wiener in
your mouth alright well I think that's
it for this week's meme review I need
help
someone send me help ng fuel for that
matter thank you guys for watching I'm
gonna go and explore it Nihon hope you
guys had a good time today if you want
to support this amazing channel which
clearly is putting a lot of time and
effort into making the best videos as I
possibly could then support and get some
epic merch and that's it for me for my
town
what are you doing
you got a snake I didn't even notice it
but I mean what am i doing okay
alright fine brofist at a hundred
million see you guys tomorrow bye tuber
simulator it's now so relevant that it's
got a brand new minigame cranium drop
the crane and get fresh items only
available in the washing machine like
game and you say there's more of course
there is new knowledge perks new quests
and new pics links and legs guys lake